à parler de la campagne des législatives
le premier tour vous ne savez aura lieu
le 12 juin et le rassemblement national
a lancé sa campagne hier pour ce scrutin
et présenté ses candidats jonathan du
prix s
en retrait depuis plusieurs jours marine
le pen se doit de reprendre la main en
vue des législatives
car face à elle jean luc mélenchon dans
sa posture de rassembleur de la gauche
entend lui ravir le titre de premier
opposant à emmanuel macron à l'issue des
législatives
hors de question pour elle alors marine
le pen frappe fort le chef de file des
insoumis devait bien qu'un certain
nombre de personnes cherchent à exister
parce qu'ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas
atteint le second tour mais la réalité
c'est que compte tenu de la tri
polarisation de la vie politique jean
luc mélenchon ne sera jamais premier
ministre en revanche si un certain
nombre de français votent pour lui il
peut transformer la scène nationale en
zad de son côté jordan bardella à
préciser la stratégie du r n en vue du
scrutin
569 candidat investi avec l'ambition de
porter en priorité des mesures pour le
pouvoir d'achat quant aux objectifs
politiques le rn espère se doter d'un
groupe de poids à l'assemblée nationale
pour faire barrage à emmanuel macron une
projection opinionway donnent le parti
entre 20 et 40 députés jordan bardella
préfère rester prudent comprendrez qu'il
m'est impossible de vous livrer un
objectif chiffré du nombre d'élus
espérait tant le mode de scrutin rend
son issue imprévisible notre objectif
est simple en faire élire un maximum et
se doter du groupe le plus puissant
demain au parlement tardivement mais
sûrement le rn est bel et bien lancée
dans la bataille des législatives
marine le pen et jordan bardella
s'élanceront dans un tour de france en
soutien au candidat investi par le rn et
enleva charles marine le pen et jean et
jordan bardella qui n'ambitionne pas de
gagner cette campagne des législatives
ils veulent incarner l'opposition est ce
que c'est pas politiquement un peu
étrange de entamé une campagne en disant
que de toute façon va pas la gagner en
fait c'est un peu le coup de génie
politique de jean luc mélenchon d'avoir
commencé cette campagne en disant voilà
moi je me présente aux législatives et
mon objectif c'est d'être élu premier
ministre d'avoir une majorité large de
l'assemblée nationale dans les faits on
peut sans se risquer à dire que
arithmétiquement c'est quasiment
impossible mais qu'est ce que réussir
qu'est ce que avoir une victoire aux
élections législatives s'est pas
seulement avoir un groupe majoritaire
large ce qui arrive assez mécaniquement
au président de la république élu c'est
le logique des institutions quand les
législatives arrivent juste après la
présidentielle pour le rassemblement
national avoir une victoire c'est déjà
avoir un groupe c'est à dire 15 députés
c'est quelque chose qui est inédit qui
n'est pas arrivé depuis 1986 est encore
en 1986 c'est parce que c'était à la
proportionnelle donc un mode de scrutin
beaucoup plus favorable au rassemblement
national là quand on voit en fait il y
adonner dont partout dans les
territoires notamment dans les zones de
force du racing en national marine le
pen a progressé en voix et en
pourcentage qui lui permet d'avoir une
ambition un peu réhaussée par rapport à
2010 est tous là c'était vraiment
décevant d'avoir sept députés on sait ce
que c'est ne pas avoir de groupe à
l'assemblée nationale c'est avoir très
peu de temps de parole d'attendre le
tourniquet pour pouvoir parler on a
moins de prérogatives on peut on peut
moins proposer des vins elle avait
proposé proposition de loi mais enfin je
veux dire c'est et c'était c'était
symbolique s'était pas discuter ce
n'était pas à l'agenda de l'assemblée
nationale l'a vraiment cet objectif
d'avoir un groupe dont 15 députés elle
peut elle peut même ambitionner 20 25
députés et on va voir charles puisque
hier vous avez écrit un article dans le
figaro avec une carte une carte des
circonscriptions cible pour pour le
rassemblement national qu'on va regarder
avec les circonscriptions qu'on compte
déjà qu'a déjà le rassemblement national
et les circonscriptions dans le viseur
du rassemblement nationale que peu
inespéré au vu de cette carte alors
quand on regarde cette carte en fait on
voit très clairement les zones de force
de l'assemblée nationale c'est à dire au
nord au sud est et à l'est donc c'est
des terreaux déjà très fertile pour
l'assemblée nationale mais où on voit de
nouvelles circonscriptions qui pourrait
basculer je pense à la première du pas
de calais dans la somme il y en a deux
qui sont très bonnes notamment la
quatrième celle de montdidier à l'est
vous avez celle d'agde hayange en
moselle en meurthe-et-moselle l'ancienne
circonscription de nadine morano ou le
rassemblement national investi son
ancien suppléant
monsieur morand villiers donc voila et
dans le sud évidemment même si on va
peut-être en parler mais il ya la
concurrence du parti re conquête qui
fait revoir un peu à la baisse ses
ambitions et ce qui est intéressant vous
avez quelques petites circonscriptions
dans des zones jusque là un peu terra
incognita pour le rassemblement national
oui là en gironde c'est la onzième c'est
edwige il ya ce qui se présente avec
elle avait raté le second tour à sept
points en 2010 est là vraiment les
circonstances sont toutes réunies pour
pour eux basculer ce cette
circonscription cake et pourtant pas une
zone de force du r n est alors je sais
pas si on la voit sur la carte moi il ya
ma petite préférée
c'est la deuxième des vosges c'est la
deuxième des vosges qui alors vraiment
pas une terre et reines du tout mais
c'est tout l'intérêt de ces élections
c'est qu'il ya des particularismes
locaux vous avez un député et l'air
sortant qui ne se représente pas son
suppléant est parti se présenter dans la
circonscription sur les couleurs
d'horizon ce qui a créé la colère de son
député donc le député en question est
prêt à tout pour tuer politiquement son
suppléant quitte à créer une voie de
passage pour le rassemblement national
emmanuelle anizon vous qui suivez
évidemment le mouvement des gilet jaune
est ce que la carte qu'on voit là des
zones de force du rassemblement national
ça correspond à la carte des zones de
force des gilets jaunes alors
effectivement dans le sud est c'est une
région qui on ya beaucoup de
2,2 gilet jaune était encore encore tout
récemment des manifestations qui étaient
encore assez présente je vois par
exemple le loiret aussi
là je pense parce que je sais qu'il ya
des gis les jeunes qui se présentent
aussi aux législatives dans cette danse
et jean des jeunes qui sont assez
connues figure il ya olive olive
notamment qu est une figure de assez
liveur assez avec de l' influence donc
oui bien sûr ce vote ce vote
rassemblement national
correspond à des votes de colère et à
des populations qui ont manifesté avec
les jeunes on va y revenir bien sûr dans
quelques instants puisque on a
longuement parlé des gilets jaunes mais
pour revenir un mot sur la politique
marine le pen on l'a compris elle est
dans la bataille de l'opposition avec
jean luc mélenchon son but dans ces
législatives c'est de prendre la tête de
l'opposition est-ce que du coup c'est
pas une erreur qu'à la fête de
s'absenter assez longuement finalement
après la présidentielle quasiment deux
semaines à ce cas là pas laisser le
champ médiatique à jean luc mélenchon
il faut se marie lebée était au second
tour donc à la deux semaines de campagne
est une campagne au combien harassante
qui a commencé dès septembre avec une
compétition brutale avec eric zemmour
donc en gros marine le pen était au bout
du scotch donc il fallait qu'elles
prennent deux semaines de vacances
qu'elle se repose et politiquement ces
troubles justifie ce qui peut s'entendre
c'est à dire que les français sortent
d'une élection qui était très prenante
et ce qu'ils ont la tête tout de suite
aux législatives c'est pas sûr donc
plutôt qu'essayer de faire du ramdam de
faire un peu le cirque pour prendre là
de la lumière médiatique alors qu'en
effet on était dans une séquence d'une
union des gauches c'était peut-être des
efforts un peu vain tout l'enjeu
maintenant qu'est revenue de vacances
que cette union de la gauche s'est faite
et que on va avoir une séquence très
électorale s'est en effet de d'imprimer
dans les médias de faire des belles
campagnes avec des candidats qu'à prime
ce qui est intéressant c'est quand on ya
une sorte de parallèle à faire il ya
cinq ans c'est à dire que marine le pen
était au second tour jean luc mélenchon
ne l'était pas et jusqu'à assez tard
dans la première année du premier cap du
premier quinquennat démène le maquereau
les français jugent que c'est jean luc
mélenchon le principal opposant à
emmanuel macron jusqu'à je crois jusqu'à
haut
oui jusqu'à décembre enfin s'il ya une
colère sociale sauf que dans les
sondages marine le pen était toujours
donné en duels au second tour pour la
prochaine présidentielle avec emmanuel
macron donc en effet c'est important
d'avoir ce totem de premier opposant au
chef de l'état
maintenant c'est ça permet d'avoir un
focus médiatique sur soi de faire parler
de soi mais les réalités électorales
sont en outre et vous l'avez dit parler
il ya la question de reconquête puisque
l'un des faits politiques acté hier par
l'assemblée nationale c'est l'absence
d'accord avec le parti tout à fait on
l'a vu dans le reportage déjà tendu
priait saint leu et rennes a investi
cinq cent soixante neuf candidats aux
élections législatives sur 577 sièges
les seule circonscription où le parti ne
présente personne c'est pour ménager des
personnalités alliées du mouvement on
voit à gauche nicolas dupont aignan ou à
droite emmanuel ménard dans l'hérault un
tel geste ne sera pas reproduit pour
reconquête par exemple le parti a
investi un candidat face à stanislas
frigo le chef de file des jeunes avec
zemmour et qui se présentent dans le
vaucluse même chose dans la
circonscription sur laquelle lorgne eric
zemmour lui même la quatrième
circonscription du var celle de saint
tropez où il pourrait être candidat ça
pourrait être annoncée dans les 48
heures à la presse quotidienne régionale
alors comment expliquer cette décision
et cette intransigeance du r'n envers
reconquête écoutez jordan bardella hier
c'était l'une des premières questions
des journalistes et faire des accords
pour des accords c'est à dire pour faire
plaisir à des appareils partisans à mon
sens aucun intérêt faire des accords sur
la base de travail et deux mains à la
question par exemple de l'immigration
avec les éventuels député de reconquête
ça ne pose aucun problème mais soutenir
dès le mois de juin des candidats
reconquête qui pourraient voter pour la
retraite à 65 ans de monsieur macron là
ça poserait un problème je crois que ce
serait une forme de reniements et
trahison à l'égard des 13 millions et
demi de français qui ont voté pour nous
à la présidentielle et redonne bardella
de rajouter et que reconquête avec
seulement 7 % au premier tour d'élection
présidentielle
eh bien le parti ne sera en mesure de se
qualifier dans aucune circonscription au
second tour et quant à eric s'il décide
de se présenter il part au carton à dire
d'une bardella hier ouais c'est quoi la
stratégie jordan base est là c'est de se
dire de toute façon ce second tour des
législatives ces second tour des
législatives ce front de rue en duel et
que de toute façon eric zemmour sera
contraint de rejoindre marine le pen le
même pari qu'à la présidentielle je
pense que il ne pense pas du tout un
ralliement d'eric zemmour à marine le
pen quand on regarde ces deux forces on
peut se dire arithmétiquement et
rationnellement ça serait assez logique
qui ce qu'elles sentent enfin on a une
force nationaliste contre l'immigration
qui a touché des csp + une sociologie
proche de la manif pour tous assez
reconquête est finalement un parti
nationaliste qui est contre
l'immigration et qui touche une
sociologie proche des idées jaune et qui
est hégémonique dans les classes
populaires
quand vous avez deux forces qui pensent
sur beaucoup de choses la même chose et
qui touchent pas les mêmes territoires
pal et même électorat bas entendez-vous
sauf que pourquoi on est passionné de
politique parce que c'est de l'humain
bah oui parce que c'est pas que des
chiffres et il se trouve que il ya eu
sept mois de campagne d'une brutalité me
sens non entre marine le pen et eric
zemmour et que l'un a beau feindre de
temps de la main l'autre a beau dire oui
nous travaillerons avec ses députés à
l'assemblée nationale tout en sachant
qu'il n'y en aura pas faim en fait ils
se ce sont des adversaires à mort ce
sont des adversaires à mort et chacun
avec une stratégie différente compte sur
ces élections là essayer ces prochaines
années pour supplanter l'autre
[Musique]